Robert cutting their author of the book
the end of lays a fair national purpose
the global economy after the Cold War
it's a lot but let me start with with
lays a fair what does that mean it means
a self-regulating economy it is the
article of faith that the Reagan
administration wrote into town believing
in and it was of course Adam Smith who
started this all but but the notion is
that the economy works best if the
government leaves it alone and we've had
a 10 plus year market test of that
proposition and my argument is that it
doesn't work very well way a book now I
think two reasons first of all the Cold
War ended even though we're still having
our skirmishes with mr. Gorbachev and
mr. Gorbachev is having his own problems
but when the Berlin Wall came down the
burden that the United States has been
carrying disproportionately for forty
five years and which has been renewed in
the Persian Gulf to some extent but that
burden for the first time since the Cold
War began ought to be lighter the
east-west conflict doesn't define
everything the way it used to the
European community Germany in particular
Japan have come of age and they could be
carrying a bigger load and the United
States then has the Running Room to look
to its own national economic interests
in a way that wasn't possible when we
were leader of the Alliance in the Cold
War was the main thing that mattered
secondly it's no secret that the
American economy is in trouble that we
spent almost a decade savaging anything
that was public and celebrating anything
that was private and some of that was
salutary some of it liberated
entrepreneurial energies but it also
brought us the Savings and Loan scandal
it brought us an economy that has failed
to invest him public facilities that
puts too much of its scientific spending
into the military we have some very
big Lluis Caroline deregulation where it
looked good and for the first few years
it delivered some bargains but after a
while all it delivered was the worst
kind of monopoly so I think the jury is
in on lazy fare and it's a it's a very
utopian philosophy it's very nice when
you read it in a textbook but somehow
deregulated banks don't operate quite
the way the theory says they were
supposed to operate deregulated airlines
don't deliver bargains they end up
gouging consumers and losing money it's
bad for the airlines is bad for the
consumer itself there are a lot of cases
where the theory just didn't pan out so
two reasons the end of the Cold War
creates a break gives us some
opportunity to try something new and the
experiment didn't work what do you think
of this war I think like most Americans
I have very ambivalent feelings about
this war I do not think Saddam Hussein
is anything but a tyrant I think however
that the war has caused the
administration in the country to take
its eye off the ball I say that in two
respects if secretary Baker had come to
the president in July of 1990 and said
mr. president in the next 12 months
there are going to be two threats to
world order we only have the resources
and the attention span to concentrate on
one of them one is Iraq's invasion of
Kuwait terrible thing
this man Saddam Hussein is a tyrant
Kuwait supplies a lot of oil it's a
friendly regime he has to be stopped
the other threat mr. president is that
perestroika and glass nose are going to
go down the drain the Soviet Union is
going to turn back into a dictatorship
the Reformers who have had mr. Gorbachev
see ear are going to be swept aside and
unlike Iraq we know that the Soviet
Union has nuclear weapons it has 300
million people it's been our adversary
since 1944 or 1948 I mean which of these
two theatres mr. president should be top
priority if you had posed that question
that way
it's not at all foregoing conclusion
that Kuwait is a higher priority than
the Soviet Union and yet the
administration has been obsessed with
the Middle East I I don't say we should
have done nothing but my own view is
that having contained the Soviet Union
for 45 years having contained Fidel
Castro for 30 years we might have
pursued a policy of containing Saddam
Hussein neutralizing his nuclear and his
chemical and biological capabilities
selectively doing airstrikes rather than
a shooting war and not only did we take
our eye off the ball as far as the fate
of the Soviet Union is concerned we have
hardly given the Soviet Union a nickel
we haven't given the moral support we
have kept our distance we have created a
kind of self-fulfilling prophecy where
we didn't quite trust it we didn't quite
trust at the corner had been turned and
so we were quite content to say see we
told you so Gorbachev wasn't really a
Democrat small deep they didn't really
mean what they said about economic
reform and it's it's drifting into the
sunset and our attitude is well this
doesn't concern us this is their problem
of course it does concern us I also
think we took our eye off the ball as
far as the economy is concerned all of
these big issues that we keep hearing
about health care costs being out of
control banks going down the drain
America not investing enough in its
public facilities too much of our
research and development money in
military all of these issues demand
presidential attention if you just let
them default to the lowest common
denominator of interest group pressures
so that a deal is cut among the
hospitals and the pharmaceutical
companies and the doctors and the big
insurance carriers that's not good
health policy or if you reregulate or
recapitalize banks by having a little
bit for the commercial banks a little
bit for Wall Street keep the insurance
companies happy make sure the FDIC and
the Federal Reserve and the controller
of the currency each got a piece of the
action that's not good policy all these
difficult issues demand presidential
attention and yet presidential attention
is elsewhere so I think we will pay for
this
whay robert kuttner is economics
correspondent of a new republic a
contributing columnist for Businessweek
and founding co-editor of the new
liberal quarterly The American Prospect
don't see people very often anymore
saying that they're liberal well I'm a
liberal and before they ship me off to
the Smithsonian your viewers might as
well see what one looks like what does
that mean
oh it means that I believe in a mixed
economy I believe that this is of course
a capitalist system where most ownership
is private where most jobs are provided
through the private sector but as the
title of my book the end of lasers fair
indicates I don't believe that the
economy runs itself you always been a
liberal I have always been a liberal my
family wasn't especially political but I
grew up as I started reading and as I
started thinking was with great
appreciation for Roosevelt and the great
appreciation for John Kennedy and great
skepticism about the dogma that says
that everything the private sector does
is by definition good and everything the
public sector does is by definition bad
I'm a product of public schools where
New York when my suburbs when my father
died we managed to stay barely in the
middle class because of survivorship
pensions that my mother taught through
Social Security and I think that there
is a constructive role for the
government and doesn't mean the
government runs everything on the
contrary the government can't run
everything but you need a balance
between the public realm and the private
realm in the past decade a lot of good
Americans who played by the rules
suddenly found themselves without a job
because the company one day are
relocated were decided to phase out a
division or a company was subject to a
hostile takeover and all of a sudden the
implicit social contract that an
employee enters into with his employer
play by the rules you give an honest
day's work and you expect something in
return
that contract
is abrogated unilaterally people who
thought that when they reached a certain
age they would be able to buy a house
all of a sudden that can't afford a
house we've seen what's happening with
the banks in the SNL's we saw the
promise of airline deregulation and that
that nice period where you could book a
cheap flight on a newly competitive
airline lasted for a few years and then
the major carriers just done these guys
out of business by selective price
discrimination so a society that that is
all private a radically individual a
society that doesn't have any
consciousness for the public wheel is
not sustainable as a society and it's
it's not efficient as an economy on the
back of the jacket reasoned and
provocative the end of laissez faire may
well change the terms of the debate
about America's policies in the post
Cold War period a refreshing reminder of
the need for both vision and pragmatism
unquote Mario Cuomo governor of New York
does that mean that he endorses your
book and that you endorse him as a
politician well I don't endorse him and
I assume he endorses the book only to
the extent that he feels that it was
interesting to read I do think that the
kind of thing I talk about in this book
is an alternative to the public
philosophy we've had in the past 10
years and it is the kind of philosophy
and the kind of program which somebody
like Mario Cuomo or Dick Gephardt or
George Mitchell or even for that matter
Sam Nunn or Lloyd Bentsen where governor
Clinton might run on because the
Democrats since Roosevelt have believed
in a mixed economy my last book previous
book was about the Democratic Party and
the politics and economics of
maintaining a mixed economy where there
is a constructive role for the
government has become harder in a period
when the economy is globalized that's
why a large part of this book is about
the International economy it's it's
harder to have an economic policy when
you're corporations are free to run to
Taiwan harder to
minimum wage laws harder to have
industrial policy harder to regulate
your banks when your banks control off
short of the grand Caymans so my attempt
in the book is to talk about what it
means what it entails to have this sort
of Roosevelt e'en mixed economy when the
economy is globalized and I would hope
that Governor Cuomo and the other
candidates read the book and learn
something from the book and maybe even
run on some of the things that are in
the book I'm a Democrat I mean I'm a big
no-no no bones about that but I'm not
advising any candidates and I'm not
taking sides in the primary and I am
mainly a journalist not a political
activist we read the bio earlier and
talked about and being a economics
correspondent for The New Republic what
kind of a range what do you have with it
I do six major pieces a year for them
and the the New Republic is really a
symposium of different viewpoints it was
once a fairly predictable magazine it
publishes people like me and people for
that matter like John Judas who calls
himself a socialist it also publishes
people like Charles Krauthammer and Fred
Barnes who think of themselves as
conservative and it's a it's a marvelous
outlet because it's it's very well
edited it's always fun to read and it's
never predictable and I would like to
think that they published me because my
kind of liberalism is not knee-jerk
easily predicted liberalism who what
kind of feedback you get under and
everybody's what kind of people read it
that come up here and say hey Bob I saw
your piece and it was provocative I mean
you get some sense of what kind of an
outreach it has oh I think I mean New
Republic has a circulation of about a
hundred thousand I suppose it's what you
would call an opinion leader magazine
people who follow politics people who
are political junkies people who are
interested in policy conservatives seem
to be reading it almost as faithfully as
liberals it has a it's the kind of
magazine that you get it in the mail and
you read it it it's a page-turner it's
cleverly edited it's
it's well-written and what I attempt to
do my own work is to take economics
which is a fairly daunting subject and
demystified I'm not a PhD economist I
suppose one of the reasons that I'm not
a PhD economist is that I found
economics almost as boring as most other
people find it to be and I was too
Restless to be narrowed in to that
economic paradigm and so what I try to
do is write economics so that any
thinking person can follow what I'm
talking about
what is your I'm a master's political
scientist master's degree level
political scientist from from Berkeley I
did some independent study at the London
School of Economics in economics but
mainly I'm a journalist I mean I started
out as a magazine writer I did some time
on the Washington Post and then I went
to the Senate Banking Committee where I
was their chief investigator and I like
to say that I really learned my
economics as a congressional
investigator through the Chairman
Proxmire that was in the mid 70s the
reason I asked about the New Republic
one and compare that with contributing
columnist for Businessweek what's the
difference there how often do you write
for them and what kind of reactions you
get from that publication
well Businessweek has a stable of
contributing columnist who publish write
every fourth week and they have sort of
won one fairly Orthodox conservative one
fairly unorthodox conservative one
fairly Orthodox liberal and one fairly
unorthodox liberal and I guess I'm the
unorthodox liberal Businessweek is
unusual among business magazines and
that Business Week is not a simple
cheerleader for lazy fair business week
is more pragmatic Business Week
editorially and in its news coverage for
that matter is not ideologically hostile
to the idea that government has any kind
of a role to play in the economy I think
the Wall Street Journal editorial page
Barron's weekly some of the other
business outlets are more doctrinaire
supporters of Adam Smith Business Week a
certainly pro-business but it
understands that to be pro-business is
not necessarily to be anti-government
but most of our industry
competitors have a hand in glove
relationship between government and
business which turns out to be good for
Japanese business good for German
business good for French business and I
think it's it's not an accident that
Business Week would find me congenial
and I would find them congenial
come on I'm doing that I guess since
1985 let me go back to the you know
co-editor of liberal quarterly The
American Prospect what is that well
several people who still consider
themselves liberals began feeling in the
mid-80s that the think tanks and the
periodicals were increasingly dominated
by conservatives and that this view of
the world was finding its way into the
editorial pages of major newspapers I
think the smartest thing the
Conservatives did after the Goldwater
debacle of 1964 was to get serious about
ideas people like Irving Kristol went to
conservative foundations new
conservative foundations that didn't
exist before were set up and a whole
generation of people who were serious
about ideas who considered themselves
philosophically conservative was
incubated so that by the time Ronald
Reagan took power in 1980 there was a
whole scaffolding of serious thought but
I have a good deal of respect for I
don't agree with it but I respect the
seriousness of the enterprise there was
a whole scaffolding there was a whole
cast of characters ready to come into
government ready to fill in the gaps in
the conservative program thanks to the
fact that conservatives have gotten
serious about ideas and when the
remaining liberals of my generation
looked around them in the early 80s we
realized that a good bit of our
scaffolding had had disappeared that
magazines that had been liberal weren't
so liberal that think tanks like
Brookings which had been liberal were
not all that liberal in many respects
and so I and some other people like Bob
Rice Lester Thurow
Ray marshal of the former labor
secretary
we organized the think tank the Economic
Policy Institute which is you know
unambiguously progressive which I think
has had a lot of influence for good and
then a few years later Bob rice and Paul
Starr and I felt that liberalism really
needed its own policy and politics
magazine where where we could publish a
state of the art piece on why for
example as in our last issue the health
insurance system that we have is a non
system that gives us the worst of all
worlds it's expensive it leaves out 37
million people it leads to gold plating
over here and not enough coverage over
there it leads to a paper chase if
you've seen a hospital bill lately it
has more light items in the federal
budget and it's not good for doctors
it's not good for research not good for
anybody so we commissioned a piece by by
Theodore Moore who's a public policy
guide Yale
that's probably gotten more readers in
Xerox than it has in in sold magazines
and we want to use the American Prospect
to really do this with all the major
public issues and refurbish a convincing
mainstream liberal public philosophy
this stuff very good well did the
Conservatives a lot of good didn't prove
that I guess I can I could prove it if I
had in front of me the biographies of
the 200 most influential sub-cabinet
people and editorial writers of the past
10 years there is a whole network of
conservative intellectuals who spend
time at places like the Heritage and
Heritage Foundation or about Enterprise
Institute who put in time in the Reagan
administration who go to work for the
editorial page of The Wall Street
Journal and this conservative idea
mongering has really created a whole
generation
I have trouble thinking of as many
people say in their 30s and 40s on the
liberal side who have had this depth of
experience there are some of them those
are the people we draw on in The
American Prospect those are the people
who were acknowledged in
the underlays a fair but I think a lot
of those networks on the liberal side of
things had become very weakened by the
early eighties so I really do think that
the reason why the Reagan administration
was more than a smile and a shoeshine
was that you had all of these
conservative intellectuals to fill in
the blanks so it is but I guess what I'm
getting is you get a sense that with
your quarterly and columns in your book
and the other people that you mentioned
list its row and writes and others which
are coming back people are paying
attention hi I would certainly hope so I
mean I think the more that conservatism
doesn't live up to its buildings and the
more that the radical privatization of
the entire economy is shown to have
failed to be a magical cure the more the
public in general and politicians in
particular are receptive to a different
set of ideas now it's up to us to be
specific about what those ideas are both
the big public philosophy and the
specific policies that implement that
philosophy your think tank you have
trouble getting money let me be funny
people actor it's not my think tank I'm
one of the founders of it and group
members of the board well everybody has
trouble getting money even even the
conservatives have trouble getting money
and they're a lot better funded than
liberals even even American Enterprise
Institute has had a scale back somewhat
last time I looked the Economic Policy
Institute we had a budget of about a
million plus a year about a fourth I'm
sorry about 40% of that I believe from
trade unions about another 40% from
foundations and the rest from business
interestingly a number of business
groups do not have the same hostility to
government that the doctrinaire
ideological right wing has so raising
money is always difficult raising money
for intellectual enterprises is always
difficult
I think the are a conservative
counterparts 20 years ago
we're able to persuade some businesses
that and some political conservatives
that an investment in intellectual
enterprise was a smart investment people
who had been putting all of their
political money into candidacies in the
hope of buying access or in the hope of
getting a cabinet seat in the next
administration some of them were
persuaded that they should also invest
their money in ideas and I think that's
now true to some extent on the liberal
side that some people who who ten years
ago would have put their money into a
PAC realize the virtue of a think-tank
or a magazine like The American Prospect
our guest is robert kuttner his book is
called the end of lazy fare and it's all
about economics in the future in this
country let me go over some more things
about you you have a weekly editorial
column originating in the Boston Globe
syndicated by the Washington Post
how's that that's okay
it has about 20 papers economics is is
kind of a hard sell there they're really
only three people that I can think of
doing a weekly or a twice weekly
editorial column one is bob Samuelson
another is part rowing and I'm the third
the trick with economics is to bring it
down to people's experience the columns
that get the most attention are always
the columns that are personalized the
columns that put people to sleep or the
ones that are abstract and even though
I'm also interested in some of the
abstractions I always have to remember
that most people aren't selling my books
than like columns I try to write columns
that and in this case books that people
who don't think of themselves as
interested in economics with a capital e
would be interested in I I Bank at the
Bank of New England which folded oh of
course it didn't fall that was the
interesting story it was the dog that
didn't bark and I wrote a column about
banking at the bank in New England and
when what it was like to to be to have
my own money in a bank that brought for
Federal Deposit Insurance would have
been a subject of a run and
was a way of talking about deposit
insurance a lot of supposedly smart
people are things you don't need to
bother to shrink anyway well if you
didn't have deposit insurance and you
had this kind of a banking crisis you
would have had a repeat of the 1930s but
talking about that personally in a way
that other people who were worried about
their money and their banks that might
be going down the drain and we can
relate to is a way of warming up
economics you you you you can't win a
hearing talking about the theory of
deregulation but you can certainly win a
hearing talking about the fact that if
you have to fly to Chicago you don't
know whether you going to pay $200 or
$1200 for a ticket and why is this why
is buying an airline ticket like buying
a lottery ticket and people can start
thinking about that maybe maybe
deregulation there wasn't what it was
cracked up to be taught at Harvard you
taught at Boston University and you live
in Brookline Massachusetts public rest
before Mike Dukakis you've lived in a
state that has been run by would you say
a liberal for the last mom love years
well I would say Dukakis was more of a
technocratic
he wasn't really my kind of liberal he
to his credit he believed that
government was needed that government
had some things that it ought to do but
he attempted to articulate this view as
a as a centrist as a technician he was
painted as a liberal by the
Conservatives all the Willie Horton
stuff the flag stuff
I don't think Dukakis lost so badly
because he was a liberal
I think Dukakis lost badly because
nobody was very sure what he stood for
and then you add to that the fact that
he was fairly stiff as a candidate they
made they made horse meat of him I think
the single worst thing Dukakis said was
this election is not about ideology it's
about competence and for this the voters
judged him to be ideologically
incompetent because American voters want
to know what the president stands for
and Ronald Reagan whether you agree with
it or disagree with it stood for
something he was willing to go out on a
limb and take political risks not just
to sell things that were easy sells like
I'm going to cut your taxes
but he was also willing to take risks
for things that fly in the face of most
people's views like prohibiting abortion
and people even those who disagree with
him like the fact that he stuck up for
what he believed I don't think you could
say the same thing of my Dukakis I'm sad
to say because I think until the bottom
fell out of the Massachusetts economy he
was not a bad governor I think he made
the mistake of taking too much credit
for the good years and the flipside of
that was when the bad years came he got
blamed for the bad years in the front
part of this book for Adelle s Kutner
rural citizen my my ID is gonna love
that she's going to be 88 on the 25th of
this month she's my father's oldest
sister she's the only surviving member
of that generation and she is an
extraordinary wonderful extraordinarily
wonderful person and I'm delighted that
you left you mentioned that she just her
goodness and her intellectual curiosity
and her travel has been a a real
inspiration to me services for her did
she have impact on users growing up not
politically she just as a as a dear
person when did you decide to name the
book for him well I finished it when I
finished it my my first book was for my
father who's dead my second book was for
my wife my third book was for my mother
and this is for my aunt my wife sharland
Trotter read every chapter and served as
a reality check whenever the prose
became too mired in technical detail but
too full of itself the text was
immeasurably improved by her gentle
reminders what is this supposed to mean
yeah sharland is a doctorate in
psychology and a smart lady but I think
like most people she finds technical
economics stupefyingly boring and she's
my best reality check and she was once
an editor
in any other life and if it passes
muster with her I think that can pass
muster with with other readers who are
not interested in technical economics
when did you finish this book you know
they say you never finish a book you
just get tired of revising it
I must have finished this book probably
in May or June and then I updated it a
little bit one no when the Persian Gulf
crisis hit and I think the last round of
updating I did was in September or
October as you were writing it did you
have anybody in mind that you were
writing it for um I think I would like
to persuade the the average citizen who
may have been sympathetic ten years ago
to the idea that Ronald Reagan was right
that we ought to get the government off
our backs who is now increasingly
skeptical who looks at the banks who
looks at the airline lottery who looks
at his hospital bill who looks at the
fact that we can make a cruise missile
that can crawl down the air shoot of a
target 500 miles away but we can't make
a VCR and if you go into a discount
store and you look at the products
awfully hard to turn one over and find
it was made in the USA and I think the
experience of most people now is that
all is not well and yet the only theory
that has been dominant in the past
decade is there well if things are not
all well it's because the government
screwed up and the only thing we have to
do to make things better is get the
government off of everybody's back i I
think that's war in thin and I think
what is needed is an equally compelling
theory on the other side not that we
need to be like the Russians and have
the government run everything we need a
balance between the public realm and the
private realm
you say up on the back again
a brilliant analysis of the dramatic
shift in the circumstances of American
post-war could you have any I don't know
why I want to pronounce it anyway
Kutner focuses a spotlight on how the
assumptions of American domestic
international policy of the past 40
years are entirely inadequate for the
21st century
this book is an absolute must-read Clyde
pestilence jr. president of economic
strategy Institute whose Clyde Rustin
well interestingly enough
Clyde pressed to us with the Reagan
administration's chief Japan expert and
Clyde and I really see eye-to-eye on a
lot of things I think even though he's a
Republican and I'm a Democrat even
though I guess he'd call himself a
conservative and I'd call myself a
liberal we both feel that America's
goals in the world have not served
America we both feel that the habit of
thinking the national security is only
military and that the invisible hand
will solve all matters economic excuse
me that if Japan coerces an American
company that has proprietary technology
into licensing that technology with
Japanese competitors as a condition of
doing business in Japan and the United
States is so concerned about Japan's
support for our aims of the east-west
conflict that the American government
just rolls over and says well this
doesn't matter if Japan gets the
business it must have been for ordained
anyway or the invisible hand wouldn't
have let it happen happen that's crazy
that's not good for the United States
there was an interesting story in the
news this week about a company called
the more specialty tool company that
makes machine tools it's a it's a
wonderful illustration of the entire
problem Moore is one of the most
sophisticated manufacturer of specialty
tools in the world
it makes the tools that make atom bombs
it makes very highly precise tools it
also makes tools that are used
make everything from watches to soda pop
cans to fuel injection systems now this
company virtually got its start because
the government needed a company to
produce machine tools that could machine
parts at a tolerance sufficiently
precise to make very sophisticated
weaponry Moore has had trouble selling
its products in the commercial market
around the world because the Pentagon is
afraid that this technology is going to
fall into the wrong hands and because
its ability to sell commercially has
been so constrained the company was on
the verge of going out of business and
the Japanese pinoke which is a robotics
manufacturer made an offer to buy half
of it now that made the Pentagon very
nervous for another reason but if we
didn't have a domestically owned company
that was able to make these weapons that
would be bad for the national security
too this is a case of you know it's
analogous to destroying the village in
order to save it you [ __ ] high tech
you link high tech to the military
because of national security but then it
turns out that by yoking high tech so
closely to national security you make it
impossible for the same companies to
compete on global markets all of this
flaws from the fact of putting military
needs first and not thinking that there
is such a thing as America's economic
self-interest no other country in the
world plays this way the European
community
Japan Korea all these are the countries
look at the world economy and say how
can we advance the interest of our
country how can we use the trading
system to position our industry to
compete we look at the trading system
and we say the only thing that counts is
military these are bargaining giveaways
if it helps to give away American
industry to make other countries more
loyal to our military aims that's that's
the province of the invisible hand
anyway it would be sinful for us to have
strategic economic goals that would
violate lays a fair and little by little
by little the economy is going down the
drain so Clyde and I to come back to
your question even though he may have
different views about social security or
different views about trade unions
different views about the tax system and
other things that liberals and
conservatives argue about we both feel
that the balance between military goals
and economic goals in the world is out
of whack and we also both believe that
lays a fair the idea that the economy is
completely self-regulating is neither a
good description of what is nor a
prescription of what should be do
liberals and conservatives have the same
goal but different methods I think it
depends on the issue and it depends on
which liberals in which conservatives I
think most conservatives and most
liberals would say that they want to
maximize individual freedom and they
want to maximize economic well-being
conservatives split on the appropriate
role of the government Herbert Hoover
not a conservative held in one's regard
had a case of unfortunate timing I mean
even gotten to be president when the
when the Great Depression hit the poor
man was only in office about six months
when it hit so really wasn't his fault
but when he was the Secretary of
Commerce in the Coolidge administration
he was very much of an activist he
believed that government had a major
role to play in the economy Alexander
Hamilton first secretary of the Treasury
was what you would today call something
of a statist he believed that government
had a major role to play in the opening
of the West and in the development of
the economy Abraham Lincoln the first
Republican president was a high tariff
man so that and the same with with Clyde
Presta Woods who unlike some of his
conservative confreres doesn't believe
in the invisible hand so I think in the
American context at least conservatives
and liberals would both say that
therefore broadly diffused economic
well-being there for personal liberty
personal security but I think where
conservatives and liberals split in this
century since Roosevelt is that most
liberals feel that the government has a
strong role to play in facilitating
opportunity facilitating security making
sure the economy doesn't come
stalked by dint of speculation and most
conservatives would say that less
government is generally better
government now Gemma nate is something
that you write about throughout the
entire book please define the word I
thought long and hard you know about
using some of these terms that are a
little bit daunting including the title
of the book the end of laissez faire let
me take a couple of minutes to explain
what it means it means benign leadership
there's a distinguished economist named
of Charles Kindleberger who's the father
of the theory basically the theory works
like this in the same way that the
domestic economy is unstable if you
don't have government playing the role
of ballast the international economy is
dangerously unstable unless you have one
country Britain in the 19th century the
United States after 1945 playing a
stabilizing role we don't have a world
currency but since 1945 the dollar has
been the de-facto world currency we
don't have a world central bank but in
effect with the Marshall Plan and the
immense role the US has played in the
global economy the United States has
been banker to the world Kindleberger
also argued that the hegemonic role
requires the leading country to have
relatively open markets so that there's
a place for the products of other
countries to find buyers even if other
countries are somewhat protectionist now
the trouble with this is that if you
were strong enough both militarily and
economically as we were in 1945 you can
do this for 10 to 20 years but after a
while and professor Paul Kennedy made
this point and his book got the rise and
decline of the great powers after a
while the role of Atlas begins to take a
toll on Atlas and I think the reasons
for that are both the sheer cost of
military spending and the warping of
your economy that sets in when you're
very good at making missiles and not so
good at making VCRs when so
much of your scientific and technical
know-how goes into the military side and
when your military role in the world
causes you to tolerate a trading system
where other countries can put up
barriers against your products but you
feel constrained to fling your markets
open to other people's products and I
think that's the pickle we've gotten
ourselves into we could afford it in
1950 we had almost half the world's
industrial production in 1950 we had
most of the world's gold in 1950 all of
the rest of the capitalist world was
flat on its back in 1950 well that's no
longer the case where a debtor we have
lost major shares of everything from
consumer electronics to autos to steel
and yet if you look at the Persian Gulf
we are still carrying the lion's share
of the military burden most other
countries think of this is our war
they're contributing some money they're
contributing a few troops but they view
this as Washington's show and they like
this division of labor they love the
fact that we are the super power and
they increasingly are the super economy
and this is what psychologists call a
codependency this is a sickness that
requires both parties to conspire in the
continuation of these roles if the
United States made it clear that it
wasn't going to carry the military load
by itself and that it was going to be
tougher in defining and advocating its
economic interest other countries would
have to adjust but we are so enamored of
this superpower role and so enamoured of
lays affair that we let Europe and Japan
be free riders on the system we let them
pursue their economic self-interest and
we think it's a bad thing to have an
economic self-interest so if we can't
convert them we can at least set a good
example by keeping our own markets open
it doesn't serve the American national
interests anymore I ask you one more
time to define the word hegemony benign
leadership it means that the world
trading system is essentially an
American system the United States is the
guardian of the system the United States
is the architect of the system
same thing is true of NATO it's our
system where the leader of it we pay the
most money for it we are the grand
strategist of the military doctrine
behind it
hegemony is different from dictatorship
it's not a system like the Soviet bloc
where we get other countries to fall in
line by cracking the whip it's a kind of
benign leadership where we invite other
countries to be our allies through
carrots more than sticks and my point is
that the cost of the carrots has become
excessive for the US economy when you
talk to her about the naming this book
the end of lays affair did you'd end up
naming him to look yourself I did name
the book myself but as I indicate right
in the first few pages it's not an
original title John Maynard Keynes wrote
an essay in 1926 by that title rather
presciently anticipating the Great
Depression by three years and while I'm
not predicting that there's going to be
another Great Depression I am predicting
that the lays a fair approach as has run
out of gas and that it's the wrong
philosophy for the next century and I
very deliberately named the book after
an essay by Kings who someone I admired
greatly he wasn't he was I think the
greatest economist of the 20th century
he was British he was a number of things
he was a statesman as well as an
economist but he is the author of the
theory which holds that economies are
not self-regulating that it is possible
for supply and demand to be out of whack
and for the economy to go into a
downward spiral where there's not enough
purchasing power to buy products and
even though the economy has plenty of
productive capacity once you go into
this downward spiral people get laid off
I lose my job my grocer loses his job my
grocer's plumber loses his job and
pretty soon even though there is the
ability to make things there is the
machinery to make things the economy hit
stall speed
and Keynes argued that demand and supply
did not neatly equilibrate the way Adam
Smith said that they would and that
sometimes there is a need for activist
government to prime the pump Roosevelt I
think was it was an intuitive Keynesian
without ever having read Cannes Cannes
lived from 1883 to 1945 and Keynes
interestingly enough was also in World
War one the British Treasury's chief
economic adviser he was the first and
most astute critic of the Versailles
settlement which you know extracted all
of these onerous reparations from West
Germany and indirectly led to Hitler
because it so totally wrecked the German
economy that the people were so
desperate that they turned to a dictator
he played the same role in world war ii
he was the architect of the Bretton
Woods system the International Monetary
Fund the World Bank and he very much
wanted the world economy after World War
two to be built in such a way that it
would encourage high growth and full
employment and broad prosperity through
a system that was private but in which
government had a major stabilizing role
to play Keynesianism in the middle of
this century
was the great alternative to socialism
lays a Fair capitalism had not worked
people were ready in the 1930s to turn
to a totalitarian alternative either in
fascism or in communism and Keynes in a
sense rescued capitalism from its own
worst impulses by showing a market
system how it could become stabilized in
spite of itself who was Adam Smith well
Adam Smith was the father of the other
view which is that economies are
self-regulating if government gets out
of the way now if you look at Adam Smith
in the context of the time in which he
lived he was a pretty good fellow well
he wrote The Wealth of Nations in 1776
and in 1776 he had a feudal
over class that was in bed with the
monarchy and you also had a rising
entrepreneurial class and the leftover
feudal class was holding back all kinds
of economic progress you did not have
government playing the benign role you
had government playing a very
reactionary role because most
governments in that era were not yet
democratic they were monarchs and you
know you had things like royal
monopolies on salt and the kind of
monopolies that the American Revolution
was fought over monopolies on tea and
government was playing a role that
[ __ ] commerce so in 1776 when Adam
Smith said the government ought to get
out of the way so the cameras could
flourish that was a pretty sensible
thing to say but modern economics
particularly modern conservative
economics has taken the philosophy to an
extreme even Adam Smith believed that
government had a role in building Public
Works in providing arms to the poor in
in subsidizing research and the founding
fathers believed the same thing in many
respects government played a more
activist role in the 19th century in
building canals in donating land so that
private enterprise could go railroads in
the homestead acts the land-grant
colleges government had a more active
role in the economy in many ways in the
19th century then it has under Ronald
Reagan the only area in which government
has residually played a very central
role is in the military and so it's no
accident that we build these wonderful
Patriot missiles which have been
subsidized bought by the military while
our share of worldwide consumer
electronics has dropped from 70 percent
to 5 percent in less than 20 years that
is a reflection of where our public
priorities are we've been hearing for a
number of years because of the
unbalanced budgets and the deficits and
that the sky is definitely falling you
know we go through cycles the sky is
falling because the
this thing is gonna break is it gonna
break and if it does how are we gonna
see it I am worried less that the sky is
going to fall then that the slow bleed
is going to continue we have had in
effect for the past 10 years a system
where we go into debt to keep our
purchasing power up and we borrow money
from the Germans in the Japanese and
then with that borrowed money we turn
around and buy their products and the
only thing wrong with this is that that
gives them a lino that gives them a lien
a claim on our economy which they can
turn into real assets anytime they want
to now as long as they are willing to
keep lending us money we can do this for
10 or 20 years but over time you
gradually become a poorer and poorer
country I think statistically something
like three out of four Americans have
suffered a real fall in their standard
of living since 1973 which was the peak
year of real economic well-being and
this is particularly true for people
under 40 who as they move from age 30 to
age 40 their income doesn't go out much
goes up far less than their parents come
wind up when their parents were in the
same stage of their lives so I don't
think we're going to have a Cataclysm I
don't think we're gonna have another
great crash but the risk is that we are
slowly going to become more frayed
around the edges and more poor and that
the fact that there is no crisis means
that there's no radical break than the
way we do business now I hope that you
can break through that stalemate but
with ideas by offering a different way
of viewing the economy and offering a
different strategy for or pursuing
economic recovery what's it going to
take to get a liberal elected president
again I think it's going to take a
liberal who believes something that is
coherent that's credible someone who's
not listening to his pollsters but who's
listening to his own cut who has a clear
public philosophy that is convincing to
the voters I think it's also going to
take a discrediting of the conservative
philosophy and I don't think it's either
necessary or seemly to say as soon as
the next depression comes a liberal will
get elected president if that were the
only way a liberal could get elected
president liberalism would hardly be
worth having so and I also think that
the economy in 1992 was going to be a
mess I'm not one of those people who
thinks that the recession was caused by
the war and therefore will be cured by
the end of the war I think there are
deep structural problems in the American
economy the permanent deficit the habit
of foreign borrowing the weakness of
American banks it is bizarre to read the
stock market pages and then on the
facing page of the business section of
your local paper airlines are in the
toilet cars are in the toilet real
estate is in the toilet this industry
after that industry after that industry
are all in trouble and yet somehow the
stock market is euphoric mainly because
the war is not doing as much damage as
we fear the price of oil is not going
through the roof interest rates are down
a little bit because the Fed is easing
and so the stock market has decided that
it overreacted on the other side and
then everybody gets in on the gravy
train which bids up the price of stocks
still further I don't think that's gonna
last and I don't think that you're going
to see the kind of quick recovery that a
lot of economists are predicting yeah
can a candidate win the election with
his or her own talent or is it going to
depend on the economy and you basically
said it said this but I you know the
Conservatives gonna have to be
discredited but is there a candidate out
there that you see that's clever enough
they can come along and mount a campaign
that given a decline in the economy can
win we've got two variables how bad is
the economy and how good is the
candidate I think if the economy is
moderately bad which which I think it
will be I think any of the field who are
usually mentioned and I would include
Cuomo Mitchell Gephardt
maybe Clinton maybe Benson
maybe even Gore and none you'd be
happier those well happy is a real happy
as a relative term it would depend on
what they ran on Mike Dukakis was a
pretty good governor he was an
absolutely rotten candidate for
president he thought of himself as
something of a liberal he didn't run as
anything but a technocrat so I can
envision any of these guys being gun-shy
and taking advice from the pollsters and
running is the same kind of technocratic
Mike Dukakis ran as in losing the same
for the United States but I could also
envision under different circumstances
several of them running as good economic
progressives who believe that there's a
constructive role for government who
believe that lays a Fiat is a fraud and
most of the American people I shouldn't
believe that if there is leadership
you've only got about a minute Knopf
2295 in the bookstore's
a year from now if I run into you and I
ask you how did you book do what would
you call success well if the book had
some influence I mean I think a
successful sale of a public affairs book
is fifteen or twenty thousand copies and
up but the influence that a book has is
not correlated simply with with how many
copies itself needless to say you write
a book you want more people are weeded
rather than fewer people but I hope this
changes your mind if if leaders read it
and minds have changed that's that's
every bit as important as a last
paperback what the book looks like it's
called the end of lays a fair national
purpose and the global economy after the
Cold War robert kuttner
thank you for thanks for having me this
was great